Stephanie is on the line Stephanie's in
Georgia
hi Stephanie welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show her new family thank you so much
for taking my call my honor how can I
help
yes so I am a medical doctor my total
that adds up to get ready $540,000 and I
did take two years off where I was not
paying for that continue to accumulate
so I have no other debt besides my
school loans my car is paid off I don't
own a home I don't have any credit card
debt um
I didn't have that divided up into sixty
thousand and one provider and I plan to
have that paid off by the end of each
year so the rest of that four hundred
seventy thousand that will probably take
about ten years please tell me you have
a high-paying specialization but I think
ho about 108 a year that's all why don't
we I know I yeah it's really odd no it's
not right it's mathematically incorrect
yeah you know you do not have a teeth
out you do not have a 50% tax rate my
contract says 180 and when I add up
what's in my bank account adds up $208
108 thousand dollars and how long have
you been doing them since April last
year okay you need to sit down with a
tax professional you should be getting
an outrageous tax refund or someone
doesn't like Excel the dollars I'm sorry
so far it's only six thousand dollars
okay
are you putting money in your 401k No
are you having other things come out of
your check other than taxes no okay
okay you need to sit down with taxpro
because there's something not adding up
here alright so the good that's the what
what what field are you in in medicine
primary care good okay alright do you
have the capacity or the the logistical
ability to pick up some er or pick up
some extra hours at the primary care
practice that results in extra income I
am looking to my device appears all
flights are brought out so I'm being
very careful about how I work honey you
just got out of school you ain't burnout
you got $500,000 in debt we don't to be
worried about you burning out your
flaming out yeah die in here you need to
be working like a hundred hours a week I
won't talk about burnout you need to get
your butt in gear you need to be making
300 grand and clean this mess up in
about three years and then you can talk
about burnout and back in your hours
back down to 40 hours a week and make
180 if you want but I want you to double
your income for three years and be out
of debt and get your tax thing straight
now because listen if you make 150,000
and you live on nothing if you'll go
back to living like a college student
and you start chunking money towards a
five hundred forty thousand not a
problem
let's pretend you put and you do what
I'm talking about you increase your
income because you increase your you
increase your income because you
increase your hours and all these other
stuff temporarily and you're going into
crazy land you're just going nuts for a
short period of time because you need to
be in panic mode someone just walked
into your office that had walked into my
office that has stage four cancer and is
questioning the intensity of chemo
that's what just happened in my office
okay yeah yeah you got cancer stage four
this requires a radical treatment plan
540 that you're gonna have it the rest
of your life I don't want this rest of
my life is in a pet this is a curse so
all right we're gonna live on nothing
you put a hundred thousand dollars a
year towards it it's done in five years
you put $150,000 towards it it's done in
three and a half years
you put $200,000 towards it
done three years that's simple and you
live on 30 or 40 or 50,000 bucks live on
nothing and you don't buy stuff like a
doctor cuz you're a broke doctor you're
a bankrupt doctor so you don't be buying
houses you'll be buying cars you'll be
investing in stuff you are a broke
doctor five hundred forty thousand
dollars in debt and you need to act like
you your hair is on fire and completely
focus and the faster you do that the
faster you're gonna get out of debt and
then the faster you're gonna live the
life you dreamed of when you paid this
huge price personally and financially to
become an MD the horrible news is you
have an unbelievable mess the bad new
that the bad news is you're deep in debt
the great news is you have a huge shovel
and a fabulously bright future your
future is so bright it's on fire if you
don't screw around with this but pop it
in the mouth hit it hard aggressive
treatment plan the patient is dying and
that's the metaphor for you get after it
get after it so all right you can do
this but you're gonna have to adjust
some things you can't just go with the
flow going with the flow got you here
you have to come against the flow if you
come against the way people think in
your world and your world people think
this is okay it's not okay it's stupid
clean it up gosh I hope I wasn't unclear